[Musik]
schwierige Offensive Putins Stärke
unterschätzt einen guten Abend um 22 Uhr
im zweiten deutschen Fernsehen liebe
Zuschauer die ukrainische Armee hat den
schwierigen Kampf aufgenommen um die
Rückeroberung der besetzten Gebiete er
kostet sie schon jetzt viele
Menschenleben und auch von dem einen
oder anderen Panzer aus dem Westen
bleibt nur ein rauchendes Waag die
russische Seite nutzt die Bilder für
ihre Propaganda hat man Putins Stärke
vielleicht doch unterschätzt die
Ukrainer sagen sie kennen ihren Zielen
näher aber können sie sie erreichen und
was wenn nicht das fragen wir uns und
diese Gäste
der Parteivorsitzende der SPD Lars
Klingbeil
rote richiewetter CDU Außenpolitiker
der langjährige Diplomat Wolfgang
Ischinger
andre Wüstner der Vorsitzende des
deutschen Bundeswehrverbandes
und die friedensforscherin Nicole
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
wie alle Gäste noch mal sehr herzlich
begrüßt die Offensive der Ukraine läuft
an von extrem heftigen Kämpfen sprechen
die Verantwortlichen in
die ukrainische gegen Offensive verteilt
sich auf mehrere Vorstöße entlang der
Front
die Orte liegen vor allem in den
Regionen Don jetzt und saporicia das
Verteidigungsministerium in Kiew
vermeldet extrem heftige Kämpfe die
teilweise erfolgreich sein Moskau
wiederum behauptet die Angriffe sein
abgewehrt worden
westliche Militärexperten sehen zwar
ukrainische Gelände aber noch keinen
Durchbruch durch die massiven russischen
Sperranlagen Ziel der Ukraine ist der
Vorstoß zur Küste damit würden sie die
russische Front durchtrennen und die
Krim wäre auf dem Landweg nicht mehr zu
erreichen
das klingbar ist bei uns sehr
SPD-Parteivorsitzende für Militärs sind
Verluste von Menschen Verluste von
Material etwas quasi normales für
Zivilisten und Politiker sind in der
Regel Zivilisten eher nicht die
Vorstellungen von dieser Offensive
klingen weil wie sehr hatten sie die
oder sind sie jetzt auch überrascht
erschrocken ergriffen
vielleicht zur Einordnung ich komme ja
aus einer Soldatenfamilie insofern ist
gerade in den letzten Jahren natürlich
auch hier in Deutschland bei
Auslandseinsätzen in meiner Heimatstadt
in Munster in einer Soldatenfamilie die
Auseinandersetzung damit immer schon
sehr da gewesen aber natürlich ist das
was wir gerade in der Ukraine erleben
eine neue Qualität der Krieg wird jetzt
gerade bei dieser Offensive noch mal
sehr bewusst man hat die ganzen Bilder
auch die begleiten aber ich will schon
sagen das ist etwas wo man sich
gedanklich darauf einstellen musste dass
das jetzt kommt wir haben Waffen
geliefert auch die gerade helfen diese
Offensive zu unterstützen und die Bilder
sind grausam aber sie lassen sich man
muss das so sagen sie gehören zu einem
Krieg den wir alle nicht wollen wo wir
wollen das sehr schnell beendet wird sie
gehören aber mit dazu diese Bilder sie
werden auch wahrscheinlich nicht so
schnell weggehen oder ist bei uns
verteidigungsexperte der Union der Krise
wäre letztes Jahr im Sommer konnte die
Ukraine die Russen noch überraschen
das Ergebnis war Geländegewinne und
geringe Verluste dass das diesmal so
anders ist haben das alle schon
verstanden ich glaube wir sollten alle
begreifen dass dieser Krieg ein
Marathonlauf ist dass die furchtbaren
Verluste die die Ukraine erleidet
insbesondere in der Zivilbevölkerung
sind durch massive Angriffe ist ein
Terrorangriff gegen die Existenz der
Ukraine und dass die Soldaten jetzt
endlich mit westlicher Unterstützung
alles tun um ihr Land wieder zu befreien
aber wir haben auch ein halbes Jahr
verloren weil nach der Offensive im
Herbst wir gestoppt haben zu
unterstützen und das fing jetzt erst mit
Rammstein mit dem großen Initiative von
den Amerikanern auf deutschen Boden an
und wir hatten eine Zeitenwende dann
auch in der Bundeswehr auch mit der
Unterstützung durch den
Verteidigungsminister das jetzt deutlich
mehr geleistet wird aber auch von
Ländern wie den Skandinavien wie den
alten und die Ukraine wird ohne unsere
Unterstützung den Krieg nicht
durchstehen deshalb müssen wir mehr tun
und unsere Bevölkerung auch darauf
zubereiten dass wir in ein langjährigen
Krieg gehen aber das Ziel ist die
Befreiung der Ukraine und die
Wiederherstellung ihrer Souveränität
damit Russland keine Nachahmer findet
und Russland verlieren lernt indem sie
ihre kolonialen Ansprüche aufgeben
kommen wir auf ganz entscheidend noch
Wolfgang Ischinger ist bei uns
langjähriger Diplomat auch der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz lange vorgesessen
Herr eschinger wie es um die Rust steht
das erfahren wir nahezu täglich in aller
erster Linie durch den britischen
Geheimdienst wie ist das mit den
Informationen die wir von ukrainischer
Seite bekommen
ich finde es vollkommen richtig und
nachvollziehbar dass der ukrainische
Generalstab die ungarische Regierung
jetzt erstmal gesagt hat alles geheim
wir geben nichts raus
wenn man so eine
Gegenoffensive plant ist ja eines der
wichtigsten Ziele dass der Gegner
überrascht ist nicht drei Tage vorher
weiß welcher Panzer an welcher Stelle
versucht nach vorne durchzubrechen also
das kann ich nachvollziehen das ist
zweifellos richtig ich vermute auch
militärisch richtig und nachvollziehbar
sicherlich strategisch politisch das
Richtige also deswegen ist es
verwegen wenn in unseren Medien allzu
viel spekuliert wird ob ein Bild das von
russische Seite nun zum 20 oder 50 Mal
durchgespielt wird von einem angeblich
liegen gebliebenen oder beschlossenen
westlichen Panzer in diesem Fall
angeblich ein Leopard wenn das zu anders
gelungen wird zu zum großen Schrecken es
ist natürlich nicht so dass ein
deutscher Leopard bloß weil es ein
deutscher Leopard ist unverwundbar ist
und wenn das Prinzip richtig ist was ich
so gelernt habe von meinen militärischen
Kollegen dass eine solche Offensive so
geführt werden muss dass du mit
sozusagen drei zu eins etwa stärkeren
Kräften angreifen muss um so einen
Verteidiger in die Knie zu zwingen dann
heißt es ja automatisch dann heißt auch
auf Deutsch umgerechnet man rechnet
eigene Verluste ein sonst müsste man
nicht in mit erheblich größeren Mitteln
und Waffen und Panzern und so weiter
eintreten also das ist ein Landkrieg das
ist eben nicht wie vor 20 Jahren im
Kosovo nur eine erkämpfen nur ein Luft
kriegt das verursacht dann ein bisschen
andere und vielleicht nicht ganz so
dramatisch furchtbare Bilder das
erinnert natürlich in der Tat es geht
aber nicht anders ein Bilder die wir aus
dem Gesichtspunkten und insofern ist es
tatsächlich eine basale Schlacht wurden
deutsche Leopard Panzer zerstört oder
gekapert wenn ja wie viele der tobt
jetzt im Netz tatsächlich eine ganz
wahnsinnig aufgeregte Diskussion schauen
Sie mal
während russische Raketen ukrainische
Städte bombardieren bombardiert das
russische Verteidigungsministerium den
Westen mit Bildmaterial über die
Zerstörung deutscher und amerikanischer
Panzer
der Lagebericht aus Moskau listet das
westliche Geräte auf darunter auch
Leopard Kampfpanzer die nun zusammen mit
dem Schützenpanzer Bradley zerstört auf
dem Schlachtfeld stehen
Wetter
prahlt wir haben nicht nur 160 Kampf von
360 Schützenpanzer zerstört auch
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge sowjetischer Bauart
aber am besten brennen die deutschen
Leoparden und die amerikanischen Bradley
[Musik]
Putin prahlt also auch noch zeigt diese
aufgeregte Diskussion André Wüstner
tatsächlich auch wie viel im Westen noch
geglaubt wurde dass wir da wunderbar von
hinschicken unsere Leos hat die
Bild-Zeitung getitelt
wie erklären Sie sich das ja erstmal
will ich auf klar greifen was
Herrschinger schon gesagt hat also jetzt
in der jetzigen Phase sind wir in einer
Phase massiver Geheimhaltung keine Sorge
das verteilungsministerium auch unsere
Bundesnachrichtendienst die haben schon
einen guten Blick auf die Dinge aber es
geziemt sich aktuell nicht an der
Lagekarte zu stehen und aufzuzeigen wo
welche gefechtsverband oder welche
Brigade in einem Einsatz nah an
Verfügungsraum ist oder schon operiert
erster Punkt zweiter Punkt der
russischen Propaganda würde ich
keineswegs glauben die führen ein
Informationskrieg gegenüber dem Westen
man kann klar herausarbeiten wo ein
bestimmter Kampfpanzer oder
Schützenpanzer immer wieder gezeigt wird
aber vollkommen klar ist auch eins
Freunde natürlich der fallen jetzt dann
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
Streitkräfte aufeinander und in der
letzten Sendung glaube ich haben Sie
auch schon mal herausgearbeitet dass wir
damit rechnen müssen das kampf- und
Schützenpanzer adlerie zerstört wird wir
kommen jetzt in eine brutale Phase und
die brutalen Bilder die sie jetzt sehen
die werden noch brutaler werden und
warum ist das so weil sich die
russischen Streitkräfte jetzt über einen
längeren Zeitraum gut zu Verteidigung
einrichten konnten über eine Tiefe von
bis zu 10 km
Minenfelder Panzergräben sogenannte
Drachenzähne stellungssysteme und es
wird gerade richtig schwierig für die
Ukraine anzutesten trotz guter
Aufklärung und luft-
eine brutale gute Kampfmoral ich glaube
weil alles was ich erfahren habe das
gerade auch nach der dammsprengung die
Wut noch mal zugenommen hat auch die
Widerstandsfähigkeit in der Bevölkerung
aber es ist schon so dass die russischen
Streitkräfte den Teilen schon
quantitativ
gut aufgestellt sind und die Ukraine
eben qualitativ von jetzt muss man die
Erwartungshaltung senken ich habe mich
heute sehr geärgert als ich einen
generaler die hörte der jetzt schon von
Enttäuschung sprach diese Gegenoffensive
da wurde ja suggeriert es geht los und
morgen stoßen die Ukraine vor und und
stoßen durch wie das heiße Messer durch
die Butter nein das wird über Wochen und
Monate gehen es wird um Gegenangriffe
der Russen gehen es wird wiederum
Gelände Gewinne gehen und jetzt sehen
wir schon an der Sicherungslinie das
Gelände Gewinne möglich sind und jedes
Dorf das befreit wird das erstmal eine
gute Situation die Ukraine gewinnt die
Initiative zurück ich muss eine erste
Frage an Wolfgang eschinger Stellen
Herrschinger wenn uns die Russen an
einer Stelle mal korrekt informieren
würden würde der besten das erfahren
da muss ich wirklich die Antwort
schuldig bleiben ich habe jedenfalls
bisher nicht erlebt hat der Wüste
vollkommen recht eigentlich alles was
wir in den letzten Tagen Wochen Monaten
aus Moskau gehört haben war blanke
Propaganda kann man subsumieren unter
der Überschrift Desinformation
bis hin zu den Äußerungen die die die
russische Spitze selbst von sich gibt
also von Herrn mit Welle will man ja gar
nicht mal reden wenn Sie es mit einer
korrekten Information mal versuchen
würden Nicole dateldorf ist bei uns und
das finden wir gut zufriedens und
konfliktforscherin in Frankfurt und
schon wirklich viel in unserer
sennenbindung toller Weise immer wieder
in unserer Sendung eine der schlimmsten
Landschaften Land Schlachten seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg wird diese
Auseinandersetzung sein muss man sagen
Frau dadrauf dass wir die schlimmsten
die schrecklichsten Bilder noch gar
nicht gesehen haben
ich fürchte damit ist zu rechnen andere
Wüstner hat es schon gesagt wir sind in
der ersten Phase dieser Offensive das
heißt man testet nach Schwachstellen an
der Front man sucht wo man am
leichtesten durchbrechen kann aber wenn
man diese Schwachstellen gefunden hat
dann werden wir noch brutalere Bilder
sehen weil es dann natürlich sozusagen
um die Konfrontation größerer
truppenmengen auch geht und dann wird es
noch mal hässlicher können solche Bilder
auch Stimmung machen Stimmung
beeinflussen können zerschossene Panzer
rodriguel hat gerade gesagt dass die
Soldaten in den Panzern wunderbarerweise
überlebt haben anders als vorher in den
T-72 ähm kann man mit solchen
dramatischen Bildern auch Stimmungen
drehen
also in jedem Fall wird das Entsetzen
über diese Bilder sehr sehr groß sein
also ich glaube wir haben das auch eben
schon gehört man hatte in Teilen der
Bevölkerung glaube ich den Eindruck
diese Gegenoffensive kommt und dann wird
es wie im letzten Herbst sein bei der
kleineren Offensive man wird irgendwie
durchstoßen und zack zack sag ich jetzt
mal so Territorium zurückerobern und das
ist einfach nicht so das wurde zwar auch
eigentlich immer wieder schon diskutiert
auch bei ihnen in der Sendung dass wir
immer gesagt haben je länger die gegen
Offensive dauert desto mehr Zeit hat die
Gegenseite sich vorzubereiten und
Verteidigungsanlagen auszubauen aber
dennoch ist glaube ich diese Erwartung
sehr sehr groß die Annahme noch ein
bisschen durchhalten und dann ist alles
erledigt und die Ukraine ist wieder in
ihrer Souveränität hergestellt das ist
aber nicht die Realität mit der wir
rechnen sondern wir rechnen mit einem
sehr lange andauernden unterstützen darf
ganz entscheidend ist das jetzt die
Verluste die auf der ukrainischen Seite
entstehen rasch ersetzt werden das heißt
dass die Produktion angeworfen wird
andere Wüste hat das unlängst gesagt es
gibt auch andere die das deutlich
gemacht also es reicht jetzt nicht aus
wir haben geliefert sondern wir müssen
jetzt in die Produktion gehen und mehr
liefern die Ukraine hat gerade ein
Drittel ein Viertel ihrer Kräfte
eingesetzt 3 von 12 Brigaden die jetzt
austesten sie haben natürlich Verluste
aber die müssen rasch durch Produktion
aufgefangen werden also die Industrie in
Europa muss jetzt die Produktionslinien
anwerfen um zu unterstützen da sind wir
schon bei den Konsequenzen noch mal
Wolfgang eschinger die Frage was wird
das für eine brutale Auseinandersetzung
sie haben sogar mit einem logischen
Argument wieder brilliert und gesagt das
könnte sich unbedingt hinziehen bis zu
den US-amerikanischen Wahlen in
anderthalb Jahren weil im Grunde könnte
wieder die mir Putin warten darauf dass
es eine nächsten Präsidenten gibt
das befürchten sie oder das gibt kein
ich kenne keinen Anzeichen dass
sozusagen Putin jetzt die
die Luft ausgeht ich glaube man denkt in
Moskau dass man diesen Kampf übrigens
auch diesen hybridenkampf diesen
desinformationskopf
ja durchaus erfolgreich führt das was
wir gerade hier besprochen haben zeigt
ja dass das aus russisches Sicht gar
nicht schlecht wirkt man man hilft mit
dass im Westen diese diese irrige
Vorstellung entsteht der Krieg ist ein
paar Wochen zu Ende dann ist ja gerade
schon der Begriff gefallen Enttäuschung
also ja ist ja furchtbar das geht ja gar
nicht so richtig vorwärts das spielt im
Prinzip alles in die Hände der der
Strategen in Moskau die denken sie
sitzen letztlich am längeren Hebel
ich will nur ein eine grundsätzliche
Bemerkung machen dies ist der
asymmetrischste Krieg
von dem ich in meinen Jahrzehnten
diplomatische Erfahrung gehört habe der
spielt sich nur auf dem Gelände eines
Kriegs einer Kriegspartei ab und
Russland das größte Land der Erde mit
zehn Zeitzonen ist von ganz
gelegentlichen Nadelstich mal abgesehen
vollkommen unversehrt und das alleine
gibt natürlich der Führung in Mosk
Gottes Gefühl das halten wir noch ganz
lange aus und unsere Fabriken in der in
Sibirien und irgendwo in im Osten des
Landes die sind
ohnehin nicht tangiert und so weiter
unsere Maschine läuft deshalb ist es in
der Tat ganz ganz wichtig dass wir alles
tun wie es gerade ja hier schon in der
Runde gesagt worden ist dass auch unsere
Öffentlichkeit
versteht dass dies
sie haben vorhin gesagt ein Marathon und
nicht nur 100 Meter laufen ist dass das
in der Tat dauern kann bis von mir aus
in den Herbst das nächsten Jahres in der
Tat glaube ich dass man in Moskau denkt
könnt ja sein
dass ein isolationist wie Donald Trump
oder Donald Trump selbst wieder im
Weißen Haus landet und dann ist
vielleicht neues Spiel neues Glück und
eine neue Konstellation und da war also
häufig dann der Wunsch der Vater des
Gedanken immer wieder auch zu sagen dass
den Russen offensichtlich der Nachschub
ausgeht dass die Soldaten sich nicht so
an die Front melden wie Moskau sich das
offensichtlich wünscht also nur auch zu
Erklärung das war ja zwischendurch
durchaus nicht nur von Journalisten
kolportiert sondern eben auch zu hören
dass es offensichtlich Nachschub sorgen
und große Dummheiten auch im russischen
Militär gibt die gibt es garantiert es
gibt garantiert und es gibt immer
weniger
Chips beispielsweise die müssen dann aus
Autos in Waschmaschine rausholen damit
man sieht Panzer einbauen kann also
Russland ist schon in der
Mangelwirtschaft aber es ist ein großes
Land und hat eine große
Rüstungsindustrie und das darf man nicht
unterschätzen bringt man nicht innerhalb
von von paar Monaten oder von anderthalb
Jahren auf Null weil ein Staat im Staat
ein guter Zeitpunkt vielleicht um zu
unserer Kollegin nach saporicia zu
schalten zu Alisa jung
sie berichten für das Zweite Deutsche
Fernsehen genau aus dieser Stadt Alisa
was wissen
die Menschen in der Ukraine selbst über
diesen
Fortgang von oder den Beginn der
Offensive über den Fortgang der
Geschäfte
die Menschen hier in der Ukraine
bekommen natürlich auch täglich die
Meldungen dass Militärs wenn sie denn
Geländegewinne gemacht haben so ist
jetzt die rede hier von 500 Metern in
bachmut wo man Gelände gewonnen hat also
Meter für Meter die Menschen wissen aber
auch natürlich dass jetzt während die
Ukraine auf westliche Waffenlieferungen
gewartet hat die russischen Truppen Zeit
hatten sich einzugraben Zeit hatten das
Gelände zu vermieden und das ist
natürlich auch ein Punkt das hier die
Kämpfe im Süden und Südosten einfach
sehr sehr heftig sind aktuell im Süden
hier von uns von saporisa aus und für
uns als Journalistinnen und Journalisten
ist das auch gar nicht so einfach hier
direkt von der Front zu berichten denn
das ist ein Gebiet wo man nur mit einer
Genehmigung überhaupt hinkäme und die
wird auch nur sehr selten erteilt das
ist natürlich ein Gebiet wo aktiv und
heiß gekämpft wird ein gefährliches
Gebiet klar und deswegen bekommt man
natürlich als Presse wenn dann auch nur
vom Militär begleitet Zugang zu dieser
Region zu diesen einzelnen befreiten
Dörfern es sind Dörfer die leer sind
Menschen gewissen leer sind wo sich
vielleicht noch Leute verstecken aber es
sind vor allem zerstörte Dörfer kleinere
Dörfer die jetzt befreit worden sind es
bekommen die Menschen die hier leben
auch mit wir haben uns aufgemacht heute
zu einem Dorf 20 Kilometer vor der
Frontlinie und haben dort mit Menschen
gesprochen die dort auch noch leben dort
findet also Leben statt und Sie bekommen
mit dass ich die Frontlinie ein wenig
verschoben hat denn dieses Dorf das
wurde heftiger beschossen in der
Vergangenheit und jetzt gerade ist es
für die Menschen ein bisschen ruhiger
wenn man das so sagen kann weil jetzt
die Kämpfe einfach ein bisschen ein paar
Meter weiter in eine andere Richtung
stattfinden wie gut dass wir Sie an
dieser Stelle haben Alisa jung Pläne
lieben Stille sagen die Ukraine weil sie
sich nicht in die Karten gucken lassen
wollen und das ist nur zu verständlich
das haben wir hier auch in der Runde
gerade gesagt wie informieren Sie sich
noch mal ganz persönlich an die
Journalistin gefragt wie informieren Sie
sich welchen Informationen können Sie
am besten können wir natürlich den
Informationen trauen die wir selbst vor
Ort erleben deswegen heute auch unsere
Fahrt nach common-schumacher das ist
dieses besagte Dorf 20 Kilometer vor der
Front wir sehen also dort auf der Straße
natürlich Fahrzeuge Militärfahrzeuge in
Richtung Front wir haben mit dem
Bürgermeister vor Ort gesprochen mit
Menschen vor Ort gesprochen bekommen
also insofern unsere Informationen
Augenzeugenberichte sind natürlich die
besten und ansonsten wenn hier
Kolleginnen oder Kollegen CNN New York
Times war das jetzt mal möglich in diese
Gebiete gehen ist das wie gesagt vom
Militär begleitet dann ist das auch das
Militär mit dem man sprechen kann und in
den befreiten Dörfern haben die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch gar keine
Menschen dann mehr angetroffen wir haben
heute also erfahren durch unsere
Gespräche und auch hier gerade in
saporija selbst muss man sagen dass hier
viele Frauen natürlich sind denn fast
niemand hier in dieser Stadt hat nicht
einen Vater einen Sohn einen Mann der
gerade an der Front kämpft mit diesen
Frauen haben wir gesprochen die haben
regelmäßig Kontakt zu ihren Männern so
regelmäßig das dann auch geht das ist
dann natürlich ein kurzer FaceTime call
wie geht's dir ja mir geht es gut und
für deshalb ist für die Menschen hier
natürlich dieser Krieg für die Frauen
hier auch einen ganz persönlicher denn
Sie haben uns gesagt es geht nicht nur
darum dass die Ukraine Sieg natürlich
ist dass das Ziel für die Menschen hier
und dass sie Geländegewinne gemacht aber
es geht auch darum dass das nicht mit
wahnsinnig vielen Verlusten einhergeht
denn das sind ja hier die eigenen Leute
die dort gerade kämpfen vielleicht gebe
ich die Frage noch mal in die Runde Lars
klingen bei Unmengen von Minen sind am
Boden es gibt die Kampfhubschrauber in
der Luft es gibt die Drohnen die die
Ukraine ständig angreifen wie kann man
Frage also an den Sohn eines Militärs
unter solchen Bedingungen überhaupt an
einen vormarscht denken und an eine
offensive denken wollen ich bin da kein
Experte für diese militärische Frage
darf man normalen Menschen ja schon
bitter genau ich gehe davon aus dass die
ukrainische Seite diese ganzen gefahren
und Herausforderungen genau kalkuliert
hat dass man das ja Wochen vorbereitet
hat es hat ja wahrscheinlich auch
Beratung mit befreundeten Nationen
gegeben die dort nur hau auch
weitergeben können also
verbunden mit den Verlusten die wir
jetzt gerade sehen die Propaganda die
man jetzt glaube ich ertragen muss will
ich eine Sache noch mal in Erinnerung
rufen die ukrainische Armee ist bisher
erfolgreich ja und ich ich erinnere mich
direkt nach Kriegsausbruch haben wir
viele Experten Experten noch gesagt das
dauert eine Woche das dauert 10 Tage
dann hat Putin das ganze Land
eingenommen und wenn man das noch mal
Revue passieren lässt wer erfolgreich
die Ukraine war wir haben gerade über
die Motivation der ukrainischen Armee
geredet ich glaube das ist ein Faktor
den darf man nicht unterschätzen und
insofern glaube ich das auch in dieser
Situation sehr vieles sehr gut
vorbereitet das auf der ukrainischen
Seite aber die Wahrheit und auch die
Wahrheit über den militärischen Erfolg
das wird man nicht in Echtzeit verfolgen
können sondern erst auf der Strecke die
Offensive am Boden andere Wüstner ist
keine Offensive in der Luft Frage an den
Militärexperten wie kann man unter
diesen Bedingungen wie kann die Ukraine
überhaupt einen Vormarsch beginnen also
von dem grundsätzlichen Prozedere
operativ ist es das was wir in den
letzten Wochen erlebt haben das läuft
unter der Überschrift shade the
battlefield und bereitet Operationen vor
Schläge in der Tiefe logistische
Einrichtungen Munitionsdepots
Hauptquartiere und jetzt sind wir in der
Vorphase wo es um die sogenannte
Sicherungslinie der russischen
Streitkräfte geht das heißt
gefechtsaufklärung durch Kampf ruhig
auch in Kompanie Stärke das heißt 10 12
Fahrzeuge unterstützt durch Atelier die
jetzt eben die Schwachstellen suchen und
vom Ablauf spricht man ja klassisch ich
weiß nicht ob sie das schon mal gehört
haben vom Gefechte verbundenen Waffen
das klar luftnah Unterstützung ist
wichtig das ist so ein Kernthema und
auch eine Herausforderung Stichwort
Flugzeuge aber mit Drohnen und Asterix
kann man viel vorbereiten man kann nie
erhalten zerschlagen Blenden mit Nebel
um dann meeresysteme heranzuführen kam
von Schützenpanzer pioniergerät
brückenleger aber auch Minenräumen
Panzer Flugabwehr ganz wichtig und da
auch dass die Lämmer auf der einen Seite
die Gepard verbraucht für die kritische
Infrastruktur die zivilbefolgung
gleichermaßen braucht man sie um die
Kräfte in der Offensive zu begleiten
elektronische Kampfführung also es ist
eine komplexe Operation
garantieren könnte und durchbrechen ist
es ja so dass die russische Strecke die
haben jetzt gelernt in den letzten
Monaten dass sie sofort versuchen würden
gegen offensiven Gegenangriffe zu fahren
und deswegen will ich das nochmal
unterstreichen das was wir an Bildern
sehen das wird leider noch schlimmer
werden und deswegen kommt drauf an und
es ist ein zweiter Lackmustest der erste
ist dass die Ukraine dauerhaft
Initiative zurückgewinnen und das zweite
ist jetzt der Nachschub dass der Westen
nicht müde wird nachzuschieben nicht nur
was Ersatzteile betrifft was Großgerät
betrifft insbesondere Munition und das
ist die größte Herausforderung warum
drei zu eins dann braucht jetzt massiv
Munition für diese gegen offensichtlich
noch mal fragen heute traf sich in
Brüssel wieder die rammstein -Gruppe um
eben genau darüber zu beraten und zu
organisieren das sowohl Munition als
auch Waffen kommen letzte Frage wie groß
ist die Hoffnung der Menschen in der
Ukraine das tatsächlich nicht nur für
diese erste Offensive sondern auch für
folgende dann genug Nachschub kommt
die Hoffnung ist sehr groß gerade auch
um auf die Luftüberlegenheit der Russen
reagieren zu können denn die Russen
schießen nicht nur auf die militärischen
Ziele an der Frontlinie sondern in den
letzten Tagen ganz verstärkt wieder auf
die Städte auf Zivilisten auf mit
Drohnen mit Raketen wurde in diverse
Städte geschossen mitten in der Nacht im
Schlaf werden die Menschen getroffen in
ihren Wohnhäusern es wurden Ziele
getroffen wie ein Supermarkt es sind
Zivilisten verletzt worden die Schutz
gesucht haben
ausgebieten wie z.B nach Mut geflohen
sind eigentlich in Städten wie Odessa
Schutz gesucht haben und deshalb wurde
diese Woche zweimal getroffen insofern
ist das die größte Sorge hier auch der
Menschen die einfach jenseits der Front
im ganzen Land wirklich in allen
Himmelsrichtungen von diesen Angriffen
mit Drohnen und Raketen immer wieder in
der Nacht überrascht werden Alisa jung
danke für diese Einschätzung und viel
Glück wir sind genau bei dem Thema und
ich würde Ihnen gerne das noch mal
zeigen liebe Zuschauer
Offensive Boden und keine Offensive in
der Luft was heißt das
was wir hier sehen ist ein DJ ohne
Luftwaffe
wenn es der Ukraine nicht gelingt bei
ihrer Offensive in irgendeiner Art und
Weise die Luftherrschaft zu erringen
dann wird es schwierig
derweil findet über Deutschland das
größte Luftmanöver seit Gründung der
NATO statt mit 10.000 Soldaten und 250
Transport und Kampfflugzeugen
gerade Luftstreitkräfte sind von
zentraler Bedeutung im Falle eines
Angriffs weil sie die First reponder
sind zur Sicherung der Bevölkerung und
auch der eigenen Streitkräfte die
Bedeutung der Luftunterstützung ist im
Westen völlig klar aber die Ukraine muss
ohne auskommen
DJ ohne Luftwaffe Herr Kiesewetter der
Kampf am Himmel ist die entscheidende
Schwachstelle der Ukrainer und es ist
die entscheidende Schwachstelle weil wir
so lange gezögert haben es gibt ja jetzt
Länder die ganz massiv unterstützen
wollen Großbritannien Dänemark
Niederlande die F16 Ausbildung
unterstützen oder wie Niederlande und
Dänemark auch F16 liefern Deutschland
hat für sich ausgeschlossen Eurofighter
oder Tornados zu liefern ich bedauere
das auf lange Sicht mit Stichwort auf
Eurofighter Tornado wäre nicht sinnvoll
aber ganz wichtig heute gab es in
Brüssel auch eine Entscheidung mit Blick
auf die Luft Unterstützung nämlich die
Luftabwehr die Länder wie Großbritannien
Niederlande Dänemark und auch die USA
haben entschieden hunderte Raketen
kurzer und mittlerer Reichweite zur
Flugabwehr zu senden also ich will das
auch als Appell sehen dass wir als
Abgeordnete im Deutschen Bundestag die
wir ja schon mal vor einem Jahr eine
sehr klare Position bezogen haben
deutlich machen die Bundesrepublik
sollte sehr rasch die Produktion
Aufträge geben für Rheinmetall für krass
kann man für handsold und viele andere
Firmen die da tätig sind um unsere
europäischen Partner zu unterstützen
weil beispielsweise auch Aufträge jetzt
von Polen und Dänemark für
leopardproduktionen kommen aber auch die
Bundeswehr nicht die Bundeswehr selbst
aber die Bundesrepublik kann noch
deutlich unterstützen durch
entsprechende Produktion also ich möchte
sehr deutlich sagen die Ukraine braucht
Munition andere Wüsten hat es
angesprochen sie braucht rasch Ersatz
für zerstörte Fahrzeuge sie braucht vor
allen Dingen aber auch Flugabwehr und
was sie eben braucht sind weitreichende
Waffen und weitreichend sind Flugkörper
wie Taurus oder Storm Shadow was die
Briten machen aber eben auch F16 und da
hat sich etwas getan und das sollten wir
auch unsere Bevölkerung sagen dass hier
deutlich mehr Unterstützung zu erwarten
ist und ich denke dass die
Bundesrepublik hier zwar jetzt nicht
ganz vorne anmarschiert aber doch
so und dann sind wir dennoch aber
zunächst bei der politischen Frage das
klingt bei die Bundesregierung gibt
hervor dass wir vor allen Dingen in
Deutschland vor allen Dingen mit
luftabwehrwaffen hilft mit ihres Tee zum
Beispiel Patrick von den US-Amerikanern
und das natürlich sehr hilfreich ist
aber auch das hat die Ukraine nicht
genug wie gesagt die müssen sich
entscheiden ob sie ihre Städte schützen
oder ihre Soldaten schützen wenn die
angegriffen werden glauben Sie dass der
deutsche Beitrag hinlangt dass er hin
reicht das ist eine schwierige Frage
weil natürlich in einer Situation wie
wir sie gerade in den Bildern erleben
aber das alles war ja immer zu dem Punkt
das ist das ist nie ausreichend
Unterstützung geben kann trotzdem wenn
sie sich angucken was seit dem
Kriegsausbruch passiert ist jetzt auch
gerade mit dem selenski besuchen noch
mal das militärpaket und 2,7 Milliarden
das ist eine große Menge und das ist ja
nicht so dass wir die ihres teesysteme
hier gerade horten und sie nicht der
Ukraine geben sondern nach meinen
Informationen ist fast alles was wir
geben können ist da und das worum es
jetzt gehen muss ist aber dass wir die
die
Produktionskapazitäten hochfahren da ist
der Minister auch dran und bespricht das
mit der Industrie das Munition
europaweit massenhaft produziert wird um
die Ukraine zu unterstützen auch da gibt
es die entsprechenden Initiativen schon
länger die laufen aber natürlich werden
auch die Versäumnisse aus den letzten
Jahren hier was den Bereich Rüstung und
was den Bereich Ausstattung der
Bundeswehr angeht offenbaren sich in
einer solchen Situation weil es ja nicht
so ist dass wir die Lager voll hatten
und jetzt uns einfach geweigert haben
sie zu lehren sondern bei uns waren die
Lage auch nicht voll wir hatten viel zu
wenig Munition als der
kriegt Material gehabt das wird jetzt
nachgeholt das wird nachgeholt fragen
wir gleich in wüstern noch mal Wolfgang
Ischinger wird diese Jet Koalition die
sich gegründet hat die auch Roderich
Kiesewetter gerade ankündigte wird die
noch rechtzeitig genug kommen wenn man
eigentlich in einem normalen
Kriegsverlauf das haben wir uns erklären
lassen natürlich Luft nicht nur eine
Luftverteidigung braucht sondern wenn
man Gelände zurückholen will auch also
wir haben im Laufe dieses letzten Jahres
oder inzwischen ja fast schon anderthalb
Jahren ja immer wieder gelernt dass wenn
man sagte ja das ist alles zu
kompliziert das schaffen die Ukraine
nicht
ausgebildet zu werden an Gerät a b c
Leopard und so weiter stellen sich immer
heraus die sind das sind ganz schnelle
Lerner und es hat bei fast allen
Systemen soweit ich das überblicken kann
ging es viel schneller
es werden ukrainische Piloten nach
meinem Kenntnisstand schon seit geraumer
Zeit an
westlichen Flugzeugen ausgebildet
zusammen mit der Avionik so dass ich
glaube dass das nicht eine Frage von
vielen Monaten ist sondern eine Frage
von vielleicht längeren Wochen oder ein
paar wenigen Monaten dass wir diese
westlichen Flugzeuge in der Ukraine
sehen können ist das zu spät ist das
rechtzeitig da mache ich mir keinen
Urteil an aber ich glaube es wird so
rechtzeitig sein dass es noch einen
Unterschied machen
gleich noch mal zu der deutschen
Situation
lebensmittelhofft die Frage
noch mal nach dem DJ ohne
Luftwaffe ich kann nur diesen
oberstreisner auch noch mal zitieren man
versteht es natürlich sofort dass wenn
man der Ukraine das nicht gibt aus der
Luft auch gewisse Angriffe fliegen zu
können die durchaus dann eben auch in
grenz- und in russisches Gebiet geht sie
eine Zwangsjacke hat also von Anfang an
eigentlich eine Zwangsjacke an hat was
ist die Erklärung dafür ist etwas was
militärisch klug und normal und richtig
ist politisch dann einfach nicht
durchzusetzen also das eine wurde ja
auch eben schon gesagt wir sehen ja
Bewegung es wollen ja einige Länder auch
Einsteigen in die Ausbildung und
eventuell auch in die Lieferung von F16
aber
die Zurückhaltung die ja übrigens auch
die USA an den Tag legen hängt nach wie
vor damit zusammen dass man auf der
einen Seite selbstverständlich die
Ukraine unterstützen will solange bis
sie sich gegen Russland behauptet auf
der anderen Seite das aber immer mit
Augenmaß tun will mit Blick auf eine
mögliche Eskalation dieses Krieges über
die Ukraine hinaus und das sind einfach
die zwei Ziele die der Westen hat also
hat eine Verantwortung gegenüber den
eigenen Bevölkerung und das ist die
primäre Verantwortung dafür zu sorgen
dass der Krieg nicht auf das Territorium
übergeht und das ist sozusagen genauso
wichtig wie die Unterstützung der
Ukraine und das heißt aber dass wenn man
diese Verantwortung ernst nimmt dass man
dann auch die Offensive und die
Schlagkraft der Ukraine letzten Endes
verringert und das ist vollkommen klar
und dieses Dilemmas sind sich glaube ich
auch alle bewusst und immer die Frage
wie das austariert wird also ehrlich
gesagt wie lange haben wir auch eben in
dieser Sendung und überhaupt in
Deutschland darüber diskutiert dass ja
alle Politiker sagen whatever it takes
aber am Ende heißt der Slogan doch
und immer hat der besten festgelegt was
er gerade noch gibt damit die u Sinne
gerade noch weitermachen kann also ganz
ehrlich mir wäre viel wichtiger dass wir
hinreichend Munition in die Ukraine
bekommen und hinreichend
Flugabwehrsysteme anstatt jetzt über die
F16 die ganze Zeit zu debattieren weil
das jetzt entscheidender ist wir haben
momentan das Problem dass die
ukrainische Offensive auch dadurch
geschwächt ist dass sie eben die
Flugabwehrsysteme in den Städten braucht
und das Weißrussland auch ganz genau
deswegen fliegt es ja diese ganzen
Angriffe und dadurch sozusagen die
eigenen Offensivkräfte nicht hinreichend
unterstützen kann und deswegen sehen wir
auch ein Teil dieser Verluste und da
müssen wir dann das heißt wir müssen
viel mehr von diesen Systemen dort haben
und wir brauchen die entsprechende
Munition
wichtiger was kein Widerspruch sofort
aber es ist kein entweder oder sondern
ein sowohl als auch neben der Munition
die viel zu spät kam und zu spät
produziert wurde braucht sie auch die
Luft Unterstützung und ich habe manchmal
so den Eindruck in unserer deutschen
Debatte das so gesagt wird wir tun der
Ukraine daran Gefallen und die muss
jetzt zurechtkommen wir tun uns einen
Gefallen wenn wir unterstützen wir
unterstützen da unsere Interessen und
die Gefahr der Ausschreitung des Krieges
ist einerseits über eine mögliche
Eskalation denkbar nur überall wo wir
zurückhalten waren hat Russland weiter
eskaliert bis hin zum Dammbruch jetzt
unlängst sondern wir müssen aufpassen
dass der Krieg sich nicht ausbreitet das
nicht andere Nachahmer finden Iran gegen
Irak oder dass der Krieg sich gegen
Moldau ausweitet und deswegen ist das
eine sehr sorgfältige Balance die NATO
EU verantwortliche Regierungschefs
leisten müssen aber entscheidend ist
beides zu bringen ich glaube ich glaube
das passiert auch ich nehme das war auch
jetzt vom Verteidigungsminister Treff
das und beides im Blick hat also das
jetzt Stichwort Munition prioritär und
das Thema Flugabwehr und gleichzeitig in
die F 16 Koalition ähm natürlich denkt
und investiert wichtig ist nur dass man
überhaupt versteht warum man das macht
weil eben noch mal Putin nicht im Sommer
zufriedenstaube wird und weil das im
Sommer noch nicht vorbei sein wird und
dass wir diese
gegenoffizieroffensive nachhaltig
unterstützen müssen und selbst wenn es
da kommen wir danach in die zweite Phase
des vielleicht gesamtkonfliktes wenn es
irgendwann Zufriedenheit Verhandlung
kommt Ukraine trotzdem militärische
Unterstützung abschreckungsfähigkeit und
da auch die F6 für die F16 für die
eigene Luftverteidigung deswegen muss
man nicht nur kurzfristig denken sondern
eben mittel und langfristig und dafür
ist die F16 Koalition die richtige und
ich nehme war jetzt von heute dass man
genauso denkt beim Munition allerdings
haben wir eine massive Herausforderung
vor allem der Mann ist da wirklich zu
spät das ist das was mich persönlich am
meisten ärgert wir haben im letzten Jahr
auf Frau Station Zimmermann frühzeitig
darauf hingewiesen dass die Regierung
die Rüstungsindustrie schneller
ansteuern muss und jetzt verspricht man
natürlich auf europäischer Ebene Herr
Borell da gibt's viele Papiere er hat
immer noch keine Analyse der
Rüstungsindustrie auf europäischer Ebene
vorgelegt aber es wird noch zu wenig
produziert und auf der anderen Seite
auch offene Quellen zeigen
der EU ist auch bis jetzt überhaupt noch
nicht eingelöst es ist noch nicht
realisiert natürlich in der ersten Phase
machen jetzt die Europäer mehr oder
weniger ihre Depots leer so Deutschland
kann ich sagen wir haben nichts mehr in
Depot und
Priorisierung ist ganz klar jede sollte
die produziert wird geht unmittelbar in
die Ukraine aber der Punkt ist eben der
es geht um Kapazitäten Russland ist in
der Kriegswirtschaft russland baut jetzt
in Verbindung mit dem Iran
drohnenfabriken wir brauchen in Europa
auch mehr Kapazitäten das was wir
aktuell haben ist schon im
Drei-Schichtbetrieb wir müssen auch in
Deutschland darüber nachdenken die
Munitionsfabrik zu erstellen nicht nur
weil es um Hier und Jetzt und Heute geht
sondern weil es auch darum geht was ist
wenn wir zu einer Phase des
Waffenstillstands geht und ich gehe noch
einen Schritt weiter wenn es darum geht
grundsätzlich Abschreckung als Bündnis
als Grundlage für ein Dialog wieder zu
erzielen da gab es von Wolfgang
eschinger mal das Wort der
Kriegswirtschaft im Raum er ist damit
zitiert worden auch man konnte es
verstehen weil sie haben auch erklärt
was sie damit meineteln wir sind eben
Friedenstauben gewesen über viele viele
Jahre und müssen jetzt auch
Rüstungsfirmen wiederbeleben so traurig
das ist
Boris Pistorius da ist in unserer
Sendung und das wollte ich so gerne noch
mal zu ihrer Kenntnis geben und hat über
die Verwendung von deutschen Waffen
gesprochen und folgendes gesagt
es ist selbstverständlich und völlig
normal in so einer Auseinandersetzung
einer militärischen das auch der
Angegriffene ins gegnerische Territorium
vorgreift
vorgeht um beispielsweise Nachschubwege
zu unterbinden das ist das normalste der
Welt solange keine Städte keine
Zivilisten keine zivilen Bereiche
attackiert werden wird man das
notgedrungen akzeptieren müssen nicht
gern aber es gehört dazu
sagt Boris Pistorius in der Sendung
gleich Herr klingen weil ich wollte noch
mal nach dem Bundeskanzler Fragen Olaf
Scholz wird nicht müde zu sagen deutsche
Waffen zur Verteidigung der Ukraine
heißt das jede Verwendung dieser Waffen
für
Belgorod also für auch grenznah Angriffe
für das Erobern von einzelnen die
unwichtigen Nadelstiche
die sieht Olaf Scholz nicht mit
deutschen Waffen möchte er damit sagen
macht ihr eure Offensive aber nicht mit
deutschen Waffen wenn es um russisches
Territorium geht stell mir vor der
Kanzler würde sich ins Fernsehen setzen
und sagen es ist völlig okay das mit
deutschen Waffen auf einmal in Russland
Gebiete angegriffen werden also ich kann
dann nur weiter spinnen sozusagen
welches
essenkalationspotential das bringe würde
und eins der klaren versprechen die der
Kanzler abgegeben hat ist dafür zu
sorgen dass Deutschland keine
Kriegspartei wird so ich kann auch
nachvollziehen dass es diese Angriffe
auf Versorgungswege in Russland gibt ja
ich
eisenbahnknotenteile auch die die
Analyse die da gerade
Verteidigungsminister gebracht hat aber
dass der Bundeskanzler sich in der
Deutlichkeit auch öffentlich äußert halt
dich für richtig
ich würde gerne
zu dieser Diskussion über die F16 und zu
dieser Frage und diese Frage nur
folgendes sagen jetzt ist klar
Deutschland kann sich nicht und wird
sich nicht an dieser
flugzeugkoalition beteiligen weil wir
keine F16 haben aber wir haben was
anderes und sie haben das Stichwort
genannt Taurus das ist ein Marsch ein
marschflughafen der auch über größere
Strecken fliegen kann wir haben gesehen
also auch wir als Laien als Militär
sofort rein damit ne aber ich habe wir
nehmen doch zur Kenntnis dass diese von
den Briten gelieferten sogenannten
storms wie hoch Effekt anscheinend hoch
effektive Waffen sind die Franzosen
haben einen ähnliches System wir haben
diese Taurus ich finde die
Bundesregierung würde gut daran tun sehr
ernsthaft zu prüfen ich ähm
ich will gar nicht weitergehen als das
aber ich glaube es ist es wäre gut wenn
geprüft werden könnte ob wir nicht
gemeinsam mit den Briten vielleicht den
Franzosen und bei anderen solche Systeme
an die Ukraine liefern würden und ich
will ihn ein ganz strategischen Grund
sagen warum ich das für eine
interessante Idee halten würde wissen
sie in einem guten Jahr ist der
Wahlkampf in USA und es gibt genügend
Leute in USA die immer noch vielleicht
zu Unrecht uns für
faule Trittbrettfahrer halten die sich
ihre Sicherheit von vom amerikanischen
Steuerzahler alimentieren lassen das
sind solche Sprüche die man auch aus dem
Mund von Donald Trump und anderen gehört
hat wenn wir das präventiv verhindern
wollen dann wäre es zum Beispiel sage
ich jetzt auch mit meiner Erfahrung als
als frühere Botschaft in USA es werde
eine wunderbare Sache wenn man auch den
amerikanischen Partnern erklären könnte
wir wissen dass ihr solche Systeme nicht
liefert oder zumindest nicht geliefert
hat wir Europäer haben uns jetzt mal
zusammengekauft und haben einen Paket
geschnürt die Briten die deutschen
vielleicht die Franzosen und andere wo
wir solche etwas länger
Körper zur Verfügung stellen dann taucht
das Problem auf weil sie gerade
besprochen haben können was ist wenn
solche Systeme dann nach Russland
reingehen ich finde es auch sehr klug
wenn der Bundeskanzler sich da sehr
zurückhält mit öffentlichen Äußerungen
ich würde auf der anderen Seite aber
sagen da hat der Minister Pistorius
vollkommen recht es gibt kein
völkerrechtlichen Grundsatz der dem
angegriffenen Land verbietet sich
dadurch auch zu verteidigen dass es was
weiß ich militärische Anlagen oder
instrukturanlagen in dem Angreifer Land
angreift das würde ja sonst heißen dass
das russische Territorium zur Gänse ein
Sanktuarium ist das sozusagen auf Limits
ist auf alle Seiten das kann ich ja wohl
nicht sein da kommt auf der einen Seite
der Strategie und auf der anderen Seite
auch sehr Ironie begabte Diplomat zum
Vorschein
wir sind Kiesewetter bei genau diese
Frage die Ukrainer brauchen diese länger
und weiterreichenden Kurzstreckenraketen
auch Taurus um beispielsweise
erfolgreich diesen Dienst Abschneiden
des Landweges zur Versorgung der Krim zu
ermöglichen und zu schützen auch in der
Luft zu schützen was am Boden die Panzer
tun sollen wenn wir denen das weiter
verweigern ist ein wie großer Schaden
entstanden militärisch wie politisch das
sind ja bei der ganz wichtigen Frage was
sind das Ziel des Ganzen und das Ziel
ist dass die Ukraine seine Gebiete
befreit und vor allen Dingen und das
Wesentliche ist dass sie die Ukraine so
befreit dass sie nicht mehr in
russischen Händen ist wer die Krim
beherrscht wer die Krim beherrscht der
beherrscht das Schwarze Meer das
Entscheidende ist das Russland sich
davon zurückziehen muss und das wäre
möglich mit solchen abstandswaffen auch
mit den F16 und viel mehr aber wir
müssen ein politisches Ziel haben das
politische Ziel ist dass das Vorgehen
Russlands keine Nachahmung findet und
das Russland danach nicht mehr in der
Lage ist politisch auch nicht mehr
willens ist solche Dinge zu tun und
deshalb glaube ich es sind die
Lieferungen von Taurus oder die
Initiative die ichinger gerade vorschlug
also dass man kombiniert mit
europäischen Staaten das macht so wie
das jetzt gerade in der Luftabwehr die
Briten und Franzosen machen
die Ukraine muss vor die Lage kommen und
das ist genau der Punkt die Amerikaner
müssen erkennen dass die Europäer auf
Augenhöhe kommen noch leisten die
Amerikaner zwei Drittel der Militärhilfe
und Sie können gleich auf die auf Ebene
der gleiche Ebene kommen wenn die
Amerikaner einfach reduzieren dann haben
wir fifty fifty umgekehrt deutsche
Führung über Lars Klingbeil wir haben da
ähnliche Auffassungen man muss sich auch
darin zeigen dass wir koordinieren
innerhalb Europas dass wir eine
Scharnierfunktion übernehmen da gibt es
sogar von der SPD ein außenpolitisches
Papier ich wünschte mir dass das nicht
nur im Verteidigungsministerium und im
Außenministerium rotiert wird sondern
dass das Kanzleramt eine Initiative
übernimmt und das wäre die große Chance
glaube ich auch dass Deutschland auf
Augen dafür zeigen kann wie ihr Europäer
jetzt nicht nur die tallinn-initiative
mit ein paar Staaten und Deutschland in
Frankreich sondern wir gemeinsam machen
glaubwürdige Lastenteilung das ist so
die Kurve kommen ihr Stichwort die
Sicherheitsverantwortung zwei
initiativvorschläge was sagte
SPD-Vorsitzende was meinen Sie jetzt mit
Sicherheitsverantwortung von unserer
neuen Sicherheitspolitik und
Sicherheitsverantwortung
übernimmt sehr viele Initiativen gerade
Deutschland tut sehr viel nein ich also
was ich jetzt nicht anfange ist eine
Debatte über einzelne Waffensysteme weil
bei F16 sieht man wo die Grenzen sind
bei bei der Frage von
Langstrecken so ich aber Deutschland tut
viel aber ich sage auch es gibt Staaten
andere Staaten die haben andere
Fähigkeiten da sind sie besser ist muss
was passieren und da können sich dann
bei 16 am Start zusammen tun aber
insgesamt ist doch das Signal von der
Bundesregierung jetzt wirklich sehr
glaubwürdig ausgegangen dass die Ukraine
die Unterstützung so lange bekommt bis
es notwendig ist worüber ich auch gerne
immer noch reden möchte ist die
politische Dimension des ganzen es geht
ja wir reden jetzt die ganze Zeit über
Waffenlieferung weil konkrete Offensive
und habe auch politische Initiative wir
haben den NATO-Gipfel jetzt vor uns es
geht um die Frage der politischen
Initiativen weil das ja auch etwas ist
ich war jetzt gerade in China und habe
damit der chinesischen Seite auch viel
über diesen Krieg geredet das ist schon
etwas was Russland und die Freunde
Russlands sehr verblüfft wie eng der
Westen mit Kriegsbeginn wieder
zusammengerückt ist und das ist etwas
sondern dass man nicht runter spielen
sollte das ist eine Ukraine die Krim
zurück bekommen zurück erobern also
etwas was seit 2014 schon russisch
besetzt ist die militärische Mittel also
das Ziel ist doch klar muss sein dass
die Gebiete die der Ukraine gehören wie
der ukrainische Gebiete werden dazu
gehört auch die Krim glaube ich dass die
Krim am Ende militärische zurückerobert
werden kann oder kann das Ziel von
Verhandlung sein das kann ich heute gar
nicht bewerten aber natürlich müssen wir
die Ukraine so ausstatten und das tun
wir als Westen dass sie jetzt
glaubwürdig diese gegen Offensive machen
kann und dass man auch militärische
Erfolge haben wird aber ob das am Ende
noch mal ein politischer
Verhandlungserfolge ob das der
militärische Erfolg ist das kann ich
heute gar nicht sagen weil so viele
Unwegbarkeiten in diesem Kriegsverlauf
sind aber die militärische und
politische Unterstützung der Ukraine
darf nicht nachlassen und ich glaube
ähnlich wie Roderich käsewetter das ist
auch noch Initiativen aus Europa geben
kann wo wir noch weiter und noch stärker
meditieren kann
kann Deutschland mehr tun
ja natürlich deutschland kann mehr tun
es kann sich sozusagen im Bereich der
Produktionskapazitäten engagieren also
sozusagen jetzt endgültig Einsteigen in
die Produktion das ist ganz klar aber
wir reden eben wenn wir über die
Unterstützung der Ukraine reden auch
nicht nur darüber dass wir bestimmte
Waffensysteme liefern oder dass wir
Munition liefern wir reden auch über die
politische Unterstützung wir reden auch
über die ökonomische Unterstützung die
schon jetzt anläuft und die uns in der
Tat noch Jahre Jahrzehnte begleiten wird
also nach allem was wir in der
quantitative kriegsursacheforschung über
den Verlauf und das Ende
zwischenstaatlicher Kriege wissen und
darüber was wir sehen wie dieser Krieg
verläuft müssen wir heute eigentlich
sagen
statistisch Betracht ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass dieser Krieg
noch Jahre dauern wird relativ hoch weil
wenn zwischenstaatliche Kriege nicht in
den ersten sechs Monaten militärisch
entschieden werden sie eine sehr lange
Verweildauer haben wenn Sie wollen und
zwar im Durchschnitt mehrere Jahre und
selbst danach wir reden ja auch dann
nicht darüber als würde dann alles
vorbei sein wir sind im Zustand auch
dann geht es um den Wiederaufbau der
Ukraine es geht auch dann darum noch
eine glaubwürdige Abschreckung gegenüber
Russland aufrechterhalten zu können das
alles wird immenser Ressourcen erfordern
die werden uns Jahre und Jahrzehnte
beschäftigen und wenn sie sagen Jahre
und Jahrzehnte heißt das für das Ende
des Krieges auch inkludiert dass man bei
einem so langen abnutzungskrieg sagt man
sehr technisch eigentlich auch nicht
weiß was das für ein Sieg wird was wird
es für ein Frieden wenn es kein echter
Sieg wird ist meine nächste Frage an die
schlaue friedens- und Konfliktforschung
weiß ich nicht ob die schlauer Friedens
und konfliktforscherin hier nicht die
Segel streichen muss weil in der Tata
würde ich das klingen bei zustimmen auch
ich kann Ihnen heute nicht sagen ob
dieser Krieg militärisch mit einem Sieg
oder einer Niederlage endet ob er mit
einem Patient und wir am Ende in ein
politischen Verhandlungsprozess
einsteigen und erst dort sich
entscheiden wird wie eigentlich genau
dann die letztendliche Lage sein wird
also welche Gebiete beispielsweise
zurückerobert werden können welche
Gebiete Patienten oder eben auch
zurückgegeben werden das alles kann man
heute einfach noch nicht sagen was man
wahrscheinlich aber alles ist hier immer
noch mit Wahrscheinlichkeiten behaftet
was man vermutlich sagen muss ist dass
diese Gegenoffensive nicht in die
vollständige Befreiung des ukrainischen
Staatsgebiets resultieren wird sie wir
werden noch Erfolge sehen davon gehe ich
auch aus aber ich glaube nicht dass wir
ein so durchschlagenen Erfolg sehen
werden dass wir irgendwann Ende dieses
Sommers tatsächlich sagen wenn die
Ukraine ist vollständig befreit sondern
wir werden auch wieder offensiven der
Gegenseite sehen wir werden wieder
abnutzungsphasen sehen und das wird uns
eben noch relativ lange begleiten
unabhängig von der Frage wie lange das
dauert da bin ich ganz bei Ihnen
muss man sich ja auch mit der Frage
befassen dass das Ende dieses Kriegs
jetzt nicht zweifellos ein schöner
Friedensvertrag ist wo sich dann alle am
hinterher die Hand geben und sagen jetzt
ist der Krieg vorbei und jetzt machen
wir Frieden das ist glaube ich eher eine
illus wurden ich halte es wer sich
anfangs zu spekulieren aber ich halte es
für durchaus vorstellbar vielleicht
sogar eher wahrscheinlich dass wir am
Schluss wieder so was ähnliches haben
wie die Trennlinie die wir in der
Ostukraine letzten acht oder zwischen
neun Jahre gehabt haben nämlich einen
schmutzigen Waffenstillstand der quasi
jeden Tag von links und rechts verletzt
wird also das ist nicht auszuschließen
dass wir das ist das haben wir aber in
der Hand wir können mitwirken dass es so
nicht kommt aber wir werden es unter
umständlich verhindern können
nicht
ernst genommen wurde von beiden ja
kriegsführerinnen und wenn das das
Ergebnis ist dann sind die Forderungen
die hier um den Tisch herum laut
geworden sind nach
langfristiger Planung für die
munitionsla Nachlieferung für die
Ersatzteile für die Reparaturarbeiten
für die wirtschaftliche Unterstützung
dann dann wird das umso dringender also
man
muss sich auf solche nicht so tollen ich
sage es jetzt in Gänsefüßchen
friedensszenarien oder Kriegsende
Szenarien einrichten das ist nicht
garantiert dass man am Schluss einen
wirklich schönen Frieden hat wie
organisiert entschuldigung wenn ich
dieses hässliche Wort nehme Frau
dattelhoff wie organisiert man dann
überhaupt eben zielführende
Verhandlungen wenn man ohnehin die ganze
Zeit das Misstrauen und die Sehnsucht
nach dem wieder Angriff des anderen in
der Luft hat also ich glaube man muss
eben an zwei Stellschrauben ansetzen das
eine ist tatsächlich
Sicherheitsgarantien für die Ukraine
ansonsten wird sie sich immer ohnehin
nicht auf einen Verhandlungsprozess
einlassen das muss nicht unbedingt der
NATO-Beitritt sein ich halte den
NATO-Beitritt zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
tatsächlich für keine gute Idee weil er
glaube ich darauf hinauslaufen würde
dass wir einer noch viel schlimmere
Hängepartie sehen würden als wir das
momentan mit Schweden sehen ein Ziel und
dann auch das dann entfernen das Ziel
sein genau aber ich glaube jetzt ist gar
nicht so sinnvoll eine solche
Hängepartie hätte nämlich noch darüber
hinaus Konsequenzen weil sie auch
Uneinigkeit zwischen den
NATO-Mitgliedern hervorbringen würde die
dann auch die Unterstützung der Ukraine
für den Krieg beeinträchtigen würde das
heißt eher in Richtung was wir auch
schon haben als Idee den key of security
compact also die Ukraine ganz genau
genau Rassismus und jahrmarktpapier also
die Idee in die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte auf NATO-Standards und mit
NATO zu trainieren und auszurüsten und
über bilaterale Abkommen Beistand
weiterhin zu liefern damit sie sich
tatsächlich mit dem Schutz der den die
USA Israels gewählt hat ungefähr das
dient immer als Beispiel genau man kann
es sich auch vorstellen im Vergleich zu
Südkorea auch das ist ein Land das den
Schutz das ist
sozusagen die eine Stellschraube und die
zweite ist dass wir schon jetzt und
obwohl momentan und ich meine wir haben
gerade putinsideen zu
Friedensbedingungen gehört also die
Ukraine möge einfach kapit gerne dann
sei ja alles erledigt aber dass wir
dennoch obwohl das so unwahrscheinlich
momentan ist das arbeiten wir auch im
friedensgutachten dass wir diese Woche
vorgestellt haben in Berlin deutlich
heraus schon jetzt muss man auch
Verhandlungen vorplanen das heißt wir
brauchen interessierte Staaten und
Persönlichkeiten die wir zu einer
Kontaktgruppe zusammenziehen können wir
brauchen herrischinger wir hatten das
schon mal diskutiert wir brauchen die
Zusammenarbeit mit befreundeten
Regierungen um die konfliktgegenstellen
die wir ja kennen zu skizzieren und nach
Lösungsmöglichkeiten zu suchen die dann
eine Basis sein können wenn Verhandlung
laufen und wir müssen auch darüber
nachdenken wie wir auch die Initiative
von Staaten die sicherlich keine
neutralen Vermittler sind China
Brasilien
Südafrika ist gerade auf Tour
richtig wie wir die mit einbeziehen
können weil das einfach wichtig ist um
die internationale Akzeptanz eines
solchen Verhandlungsprozesses zu
unterstützen und das wird notwendig sein
will ich noch mal sagen also die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es ein richtigen
schmutzigen Frieden läuft ist ja relativ
hoch das heißt deswegen müssen wir das
politische diplomatische eben mit dem
militärischen denken und das heißt eben
wenn man das sieht also ich könnte mir
vorstellen putty ist so gerissen dass er
sagt komm ich möchte verhandeln bitte er
hat ja schon mal solche Ansätze
formuliert hört auf zu liefern dann
verhandle ich man muss bedenken und da
ist man in der Analyse sehr weit das
Putin also da gibt es unterschiedliche
Auffassungen sind Tanks aber zwischen
zwei und sechs Jahren braucht um wieder
vor eine Stadt auf ein Stand zu kommen
vor dem 24 Februar letzten Jahr das
vergleichbar würden wir in Europa
brauchen 10 bis 14 Jahre das heißt wir
müssen uns den zustimmen um den
zustimmen das heißt wir müssen verstehen
warum Rüstung und Verteidigungsindustrie
ein Teil von Verteidigung und Sicherheit
ist und bevor verhindern weil wir das im
Vorfeld diskutiert haben jemand wieder
sagt dann machen wir doch die Bundeswehr
nackt wir haben einen Inspektor der Luft
war gehabt der jetzt hier gesagt hat
Teile es in der Luftwaffe sind
museumsreife wir haben einen Inspektor
der Marine der davon sprach dass das
Sondervermögen eine Art
palliativmaßnahme ist wir haben den
infektiös dass der sagt wie groß die
Lücke zwischen Anspruch und Wirklichkeit
ist also das heißt egal ob ich jetzt das
Thema Personal oder Material nehme wo
das pistoleos adressiert das ja wenn ich
in den nationalen Sicherheitsstand die
schaue und der spreche jetzt natürlich
den Parteivorsitzenden der SPD an schade
dass nicht Christian Lindner da sitzt
oder um mit Nuri pur aber der Punkt ist
eben der wenn wir das wenn wir das
machen wollen was wir jetzt auch in der
nationalen Sicherheitsstrategie stehen
haben Stichwort Wehrhaftigkeit dann
müssen wir investieren wenn wir uns
überlegen Frau Illner und da und da
kriege ich Puls das ein
Verteidigungsminister erstmals in der
Geschichte dieses Landes sich öffentlich
in ein fraktionsveranstaltung stellt und
sagt wir sind im Blick unsere Aufgaben
der Landes und finden nicht
verteidigungsfähig wenn er sagt ich
brauche 10 Milliarden mehr für den
verteidigungshaus ist durch deklinieren
kann für was er jeden Tag braucht und
ich erlebe jetzt in den Verhandlungen
dass man ihn abspeisen will mit 2
Milliarden dann wird diese Zeiten Wende
verhungern die Olaf Scholz angesprochen
hat und deswegen noch mal meine
Aufforderung bitte Lars Klingbeil alles
sind die Waagschale zu werden im
Kriegszeiten ist ein
Verteidigungsminister von enorme
Bedeutung ihn zu unterstützen sonst wird
das nichts mit der Zeit wenn du und wir
verlieren wieder vertrauen wie nach 2014
wo wir schon mal von zwei Prozent und
viel mehr gesprochen haben
öffentlich auch gesagt dass ich
Pistorius unterstütze
aber ich will natürlich schon noch
einordnen das ist die Regierung die
jetzt gerade 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen auf den Weg gebracht hat
das ist eine riesige Summe die jetzt
hilft und viele Defizite der
Vergangenheit doch
auszumerzen trotzdem bleibt klar und da
stimme ich zu die Frage der Landes- und
bündnisverteidigung das ist jetzt eine
neue Normalität die zurückgekehrt ist
und wir müssen uns als Gesellschaft sehr
stark damit auseinandersetzen was das
bedeutet und deswegen glaube ich auch
ist es auch im Interesse der nationalen
Sicherheitspolitik dass wir diesen Krieg
nicht aus dem Auge verlieren dass das
keine Normalität für die man irgendwie
zurückstellt und sagt das läuft jetzt
seit zwei Jahren seit drei Jahren und
wir interessieren uns irgendwann nicht
mehr für oder diese Wetter hat vorhin
gesagt das sind unsere Werte die da
verteidigt werden ich glaube wenn man
Putin jetzt geschehen lässt dann wir
haben beide mit unseren Partnern in
Polen geredet im Baltikum die haben
wahnsinnige Angst davor dass sie die
nächsten sind die angegriffen werden und
das erfordert einen Mentalitätswechsel
aber das ist mit der Zeitenwende
eingeleitet die Milliarden sind da ich
bin die Hauptstadt ausgegeben werden ja
aber auch mit der Frage beschäftigt sich
der Minister ja wie schneller ausgegeben
werden kann und wie schnell er
produziert werden kann aber es braucht
eine weitere Unterstützung da bin ich
völlig der Chor also wenn wir uns einig
sind dass der Verteidigungsetat massiv
steigen muss dann ist es ja gut dann
müssen wir nur die anderen
Koalitionspartner Unterstützung aber der
Punkt ist der ist wichtig wir sprechen
hier über die Zukunft der
Sicherheitsarchitektur Europas und wir
wollen bestimmte Dinge hier verhindern
wenn ich die Filme sehe mit Blick auf
Folter mit Blick auf Vergewaltigung aus
der Ukraine die will hier niemand sehen
wenn wir das sehen wissen wir warum wir
wieder investieren müssen in der
Sicherheitsarchitektur und wenn wir
jetzt den National sicherheitstrategie
auflegen und wer hat wieder in das
Zentrum rücken dann müssten wir endlich
das nachholen was wir die letzten 30
Jahren eingeschaltet haben Hunderte von
Milliarden deswegen Investition ich
stimme ganz ganz vielen zu ich will nur
darauf hinweisen dass es nicht alleine
um Verteidigung und absprechen das ist
eine zentrale Komponente aber Stichwort
nationale Sicherheits Energie mir fehlt
da viel Strategie also zum Beispiel
Priorisierung mit mir fehlt der vor
allen Dingen eines da stehen sehr sehr
viele wichtige Sachen drin auch
beispielsweise dass wir das Commitment
im Bereich der Entwicklung
Zusammenarbeit und humanitären Hilfe
auch weiterhalten werden müssen dass wir
neue Produkte gewinnen müssen
und so weiter und so fort aber dann
steht da drin dass das alles kosten
neutral abgewickelt werden
gleichzeitig reden wir heute abend
darüber und es scheint ja Konsens hier
in der Runde zu sein dass dieser Krieg
sehr lange dauern wird und der
Wiederaufbau sehr lange dauern das ist
sehr viel kosten wird und dann muss man
sich glaube ich auch soweit ehrlich
machen dass man endlich sagt das wird
nicht kosten neutral zu erreichen sein
oder es wird massive Verschiebung in den
Haushalten geben müssen und darüber muss
man endlich öffentlich diskutieren das
muss man eben auch darlegen man muss um
Unterstützung für ein solchen Kurs wenn
man und das politischen Willen letzten
Frage an Lars klingen bei warum Herr
klingen weil ich weiß nicht ob sie auch
darauf eine kurze Antwort haben dauern
all diese Dinge in dieser Regierung egal
ob Atom egal ob Ukraine und egal ob
Heizung immer so lang warum erinnern sie
an einen
selbstverfleischungsprozess also Heizung
können wir jetzt gerne das fast
aufmachen das dauert dann aber länger
als eine kurze Antwort aber was die
Zeitenwende angeht und was das
Sondervermögen angeht das waren schnelle
Entscheidung die in der Regierung Gott
sei Dank mit Unterstützung der größten
Oppositionspartei zusammengetroffen
wurden da gibt es in der Demokratischen
Mitte des Parlamentes eine Klarheit die
gab es auch schnell 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen jetzt können wir darüber
streiten wie schnell er investiert
werden kann aber dass die Bundeswehr
massiv gestärkt wird durch den
Bundeskanzler so richtig glücklich sein
oder mehr fordert aber das etwas gerade
passiert ich finde das dürfen wir an
dieser Stelle auch nicht klein reden und
das ist ein Mentalitätswandel gibt dass
ich auch erlebe in meiner Heimatstadt in
Münster das ganz anders auf einmal
gesellschaftlich auf Bundeswehr geguckt
wird dass die Sicherheitspolitik mit den
Fokus Rück aber wir müssen und das haben
sie gerade gesagt neben der
militärischen Stärke auch die politische
die diplomatische die
entwicklungspolitikstärke das gehört
alles zu einem umfassen
Sicherheitsbegriff mit dazu lange
Antwort aber wollte jetzt immer der
Punkt ist vor allem da dreimal
Lackmustest wir haben gesagt Ukraine die
lineare Initiative zurückgewinnen soll
und auch erfolgreich sein soll der
Westen der nicht nachlässt jetzt in der
Unterstützung damit auch Deutschland und
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland die den
Verteidigungsetat erhöht und Idealfall
auf die um die 10 Milliarden die Boys
pistoleos gefordert haben
an der Stelle
danke das war die Kurzfassung und wir
sagen dass sie in die Runde wir sind an
dem Punkt an dem ich zu Markus Lanz
weitergebe mich sehr herzlich bei den
Gäste natürlich bedanke und hoffe dass
Sie gut durch diesen Abend kommen bei
Markus Land sitzt Kevin Kühnert wenn ich
nicht irre und wir sehen uns wenn Sie
mögen nächsten Donnerstag wieder gleiche
Stelle gleiche Welle kommen Sie gut
durch den Abend noch mal viel herzlichen
Dank danke tschüss
[Musik]